في خطاب الى الشعب المغربي بمناسبه الذكرى
47 للمسيره الخضراء لم يجدد الملك محمد
السادس دعوته الى رئيس الجزائري عبد
المجيد تبون لزياره المغرب من اجل الحوار
ركز خطابه على مشروع انبوب الغاز نيجيريا
المغرب
[موسيقى]
نجدد الفتاح هنا على جميع اشكال اشتراك
المفيده من اجل انجاز هذا المشروع
الافريقي الكبير
تعول الرباط على مشروع انبوب الغاز لتنويع
مصادر التموين خلال السنوات المقبله في
سبتمبر الماضي وقعت المجموعه الاقتصاديه
لدول غرب افريقيا مع المغرب ونيجيريا
مذكره تفاهم بشان انبوب الغاز نيجيري
المغربي تلتزم 13 دوله بتوفير حوالي ثلاثه
مليانات قدم مكعب من الغاز لدول غرب
افريقيا عبر المغرب ثم الى اوروبا على
الصعيد الاقتصادي اعلن العاهل المغرب عن
مجموعه من المشاريع التنميه ودعى القطاع
الخاص الى الاستثمار في الاقاليم الجنوبيه
تعد ذكرى المسيره الخضراء ذكر استعاد فيها
المغرب اقليم الصحراء من الاستعمار
الاسباني عام 1975